hi i'm z-way and i'm here with buzzfeed
to read my thirst tweets
[Music]
number one z-way is so sexy and cool i
love badass women
wow that's really nice i love
compliments so i really love this
segment already this is now at seaway
sand account please watch her show her
brain comma iconic heart
taste taste i'm excited that you guys
are excited about season two of my show
when i tell you the guests are oh the
lineup is stout charlemagne chet hanks
dumois mia khalifa nicole buyer hannibal
burris emerald oh elana glazer it's
yeah it's great it's great it's great
z-wave's smile makes me feel like
everything is going to be okay
how do you feel now
z-wave is so stunning in every single
photo and on every single ig live i
would probably faint if i saw her irl
if you fainted
after seeing me i would be so concerned
i would be like are you okay
do you need help do you need water how's
your tummy that's really kind but i hope
please if you ever if we ever cross
bounce don't faint
i promise i'm a regular person i'm
really nice too i did not know what to
expect with that z-way show that is
hilarious she's smart she's a real live
troll and she's gorgeous yes i'm a real
live troll like the smurfs smurfette i'm
a smurfette i actually now that i think
of it i've never done i like my outfits
are sort of inspired like right now my
outfits kind of bratz doll but i've
never done a smurf at outfit are they
trolls a lot to think about i want
zeeway to come into my house slap me in
the face and tell me to get my [ __ ]
together i feel like i'd listen to her
what i'm not gonna slap you you listen
to your heart when it's calling for you
listen to your heart there's nothing
else you can do i don't know where
you're going i and i don't know why
listen to your heart before it tells you
goodbye i think that's a love song but
in this case make it a love song to
yourself trust yourself you'll you don't
need me god z-way is an instant classic
one of the most hilarious comedians of
our time she's also very hot thank you i
like that she's also very hot got its
own break line because it's like not
only am i quote one of the most
hilarious means of our time i'm also hot
and you know what that is the
representation that that girls with
symmetrical faces need like i'm glad i
could be that person i've never been as
in love with obsessed with or as jealous
of anyone as i am from z-way wow this is
a lot of i feel like
thank you can you feel the this shift in
my demeanor suddenly i'm like just
uncomfortable with all the compliments
and that's that's how you know i'm a
pisces oh god don't look at me don't
perceive me thank you i'm obsessed with
you and i'm obsessed with with i'm
jealous of you okay next question not
next tweet rather tweet on um elon
musk's twitter shout out to him an
african american what i love about
zeeway is that despite being supremely
intelligent and funny she hasn't lost
sight of what's important in life being
hot and serving looks wow i love it so
my aesthetic is working okay when i read
tweets like this what i hear is that you
guys love bratz dolls you guys love
cinema you love looks you love serving
you love aesthetic i'm very lucky that
you guys would say such nice kind things
about me thank you but i'm even more
lucky to have an audience that has such
impeccable tastes i am merely
a cog in the taste machine and you guys
are churning out that granola or i guess
it wouldn't be granola snow piercer i
don't know can z-wave marry me can see
me and i get married z-way call me if
you're interested i'll marry you someone
tells e-way we can get legally married
in the country of the usatm i'm not
getting married but i support those
endeavors shout out to you thank you it
would be really funny if i got married
to people so they could watch my show
but
all of my audiences are my partners in
life quote z-way is so [ __ ] fine
great that was straight to the point i
like that a lot of
comments about my boobs comments about
my lips comments about styling my
styling i'm styled by pamela shepard i
have a great great team thank you so
much for tweeting at me you know what
will really help if you guys love me
tweet about the show and tell people to
watch the iconic episodes but yeah thank
you so much for the new time
[Music]
you